[Music]
Disney Princesses are still popular
among audiences of all ages and yet they
also have endured their share of
criticism their United appearance in
Ralph breaks the internet prepares
audiences for an unforgettable comeback
watch until number one to see why we can
expect to finally see feminist
princesses if this is your first time
visiting the things don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up here's hidden messages
from Disney's princesses in wreck-it
Ralph to makes fun of Disney Princess
model what does it mean to be a Disney
Princess this is definitely a question
raised by Ralph breaks the internet
trailer when Disney Princesses question
whether or not vanellope qualifies as
one of them a BBC 2012 article questions
the lessons young girls can learn from
Disney Princesses revealing an important
hidden message overall Disney royalty
can teach us a lot about perseverance
and determination as each one had to
overcome a difficult set of obstacles
earlier princesses such as Cinderella
Aurora and Snow White have been
especially criticized for being too
delicately depicted the article also
brings up a great line that really
emphasizes how tropes and models for
Disney Princesses have been forced upon
Disney Princesses the same is that
Cinderella never asked for a prince she
asked for a day off and a dress it
seemed that no matter what princesses
want whether it be a chance to live on
land save a parent or wake up from a
cruise the early dizzy model required
this all to be accomplished according to
a problematic and demeaning set of
standards Rapunzel's self-awareness and
pointing out this model and its
ridiculousness promises that Ralph
Rick's the Internet will continue in the
footsteps of frozen Moana and brave in
showing us an alternative model internet
antidotes one comments that Rapunzel
makes when she's confronted with
Penelope is asking if she's ever been
poisoned
the implication of this question is that
a princess might be defined by the fact
that she has overcome poisoning though
this fact is pointed out as part of a
list that shows that Disney is willing
to laugh at itself for its past blunders
when it comes to representation of women
it also causes us to think about how far
we've come
Snow White in the Seven Dwarfs came out
in 1937 at the
I'm seeing a woman kiss 12 men as they
left for work was cute and charming
having her downfall be the manipulation
at the hands of a stranger who caused
her to eat a poisoned Apple was horrific
but in an entertaining way now these
concepts would provoke so much criticism
that would hinder a movie success the
hidden message is that the internet
informed us about problems faced by
people whose voices have not always been
heard
having the Princesses as part of an
internet platform actually points out
that the Internet itself has contributed
to how we have become more aware of
harmful treatment of women and has now
resulted in a lower tolerance to making
fun of others oppression all good things
passive to active as soon as Penelope
appears in a room filled with Disney
Princesses their response is hilarious
as it shows that princesses and an
uncharacteristically defensive light
instead of being victims of their
circumstances and fulfilling the role of
damsels in distress' they brandish
weapons to defend themselves against the
potential threats we might expect that a
roomful of Disney princesses would adopt
a much more passive attitude in light of
danger and would call for help this is
not the case in the scene from there
Ralph breaks the internet trailer
Jasmine uses her magic lamp as a weapon
Pocahontas has her wooden staff ready
and Cinderella smashes her glass slipper
to use it as a sharp tool to protect
herself the princesses from the past
have always waited for some kind of
action or event to happen but in the
trailer we see these same princesses
preparing to defend themselves and each
other this is definitely refreshing to
see that princesses are no longer
relying on men for their rescue that are
following new princesses like Elsa and
Anna Moana and Merida for demonstrating
strength without meeting the man's
validation what was your reaction to
these self-sufficient princesses and
their reaction to a younger and less
conventional princess a man to save the
day Ralph breaks the Internet is getting
a lot of attention because of the
movie's obvious self-awareness and
willingness to poke fun at itself it's
easy to criticize the movies choices and
it's even easier to criticize Disney
because of its questionable decisions it
seems that the rugged Ralph's sequel has
thought ahead and is instead using this
crossover opportunity as a way to
anticipate these critical remarks while
vanellope is horrified by the
classification system that the Disney
Princesses
she ultimately finds common ground the
apprentices ask Penelope a series of
worrisome questions to which she becomes
concerned even asking if she needs to
call the police
Penelope is showing the audience that
Disney is aware that women should never
have to endure the terrible treatment
that they have suffered it also suggests
that putting up with this treatment is
not an ideal princess-like way to behave
in the end the princesses accept
Penelope as one of their own when she
admits that she is also experienced that
people assume that a man is needed to
save the day this alludes to the first
movie and vanilla peas reluctance when
she first meets Ralph however it also
proves that Disney continues to follow
stereotypical tropes for women in movies
but now they are aware and ready to poke
fun at themselves most of the original
voice actors are back the Disney
Princess teen is definitely also used as
a way to draw in an older audience as it
creates a sense of nostalgia not only is
this a first for all the Disney
Princesses to appear on screen together
but they are also all performed by the
original voice actors the familiarity of
the voice is definitely adds to some
real effects to the fact that the
princesses we grew up with are all in
the same room together as awesome and
exciting as this may be it causes us to
have to point out a darker truth behind
Disney's classic princess voice Snow
White
Snow White's voice in 1937 when the
movie came out is unofficially credited
to actress adriana caselotti
rumor is that Disney owned the rights to
casalotti unforgettable voice and
prevented her from pursuing a career
after Snow White it has been said that
Disney claimed he wanted to keep Snow
White's identity a mystery so that the
fictional character would always remain
as she is it's terrible to think that
casalotti never achieves the type of
recognition her talent deserved since
2011 actress Katie Vaughn Hill has been
the only voice responsible to Snow White
nothing better to do can we just take a
second to ask about where exactly
vanilla pee finds these princesses it
seems that they are in some kind of
dressing room and when they first appear
on screen they don't seem to be occupied
by anything the princesses embody their
doom yourselves as they stood around in
full ball gowns
seems this is the room they hang out in
between their group performances which
is where we see them for the first time
in the trailer fellows reading and
Rapunzel's writing
other than that it's unclear what the
other princesses are busy doing to pass
the time
Jasmine those sitting on a magic carpet
is simply looking at a flower
much like Tiana who is just looking out
the window and Snow White who is calling
a bird to her outstretched fingers
doesn't it seem strange that these
princesses supposedly known for their
role in their kingdoms are spending
their downtime grooming one another and
in deep contemplation this might be
another way for Disney to show that it
hasn't represented femininity in all of
its aspects in past movies but it still
feels like a missed opportunity these
princesses could have been showing off
the diversity of their strengths and
talents is vanellope at Disney Princess
Penelope's first reaction to arriving at
her destination is disgust as she says
princesses and cartoon characters barf
vanellope takes ownership of her status
as a princess and this brings up a great
hidden message about Penelope's
contribution to the Disney princess
legacy when ralph first meets vanilla
pee in wreck-it Ralph
she's a princess and sugar rush vying
for a spot on the racing leaderboard the
only problem is is that she doesn't fit
in because she's a glitch and this
subjects her to ridicule ultimately
Manila Pia learns to embrace what makes
her different and unique and refuses to
give it up this really does embody a
Disney Princesses spirit as she's
determined resilient and compassionate
she also has faults that she embraces as
what makes her curved there are some
significant differences though Penelope
is not looking for any type of romantic
love nor is she ready to do so as she's
much younger than the typical Disney
Princess what's more she rejects the
stylistic tropes that princesses like
Cinderella aspire to she opts for a
green hoodie over a pink hoop skirt a
dress
overall Penelope is a welcome addition
to the princess lineup especially since
she's a catalyst for causing the
traditional princesses to question their
problematic history Disney owns
everything aside from owning up to its
sexist past and tendency for gender
stereotyping Ralph breaks the Internet
uses its trailer to demonstrate its wide
cultural reach Disney doesn't have the
same
usual copyright constraints that other
movies have to deal with and they're
willing to use that completely to their
advantage there's no limit to the movie
references Disney can make since they
have bought and acquired such a wide
array of production companies and
studios in one frame from the trailer
the viewers are confronted just how much
Disney has to flaunt as we can clearly
see Mickey the Millennium Falcon a TIE
fighter the Death Star Betamax
Ironman Kermit the Frog Dumbo r2d2 the
house from up and more these are just
visible from one shot in the movie
trailer which only alludes to the
marketing potential in a crossover movie
like Ralph breaks the Internet Disney
itself is relying on its capacity to
band fans of multiple genres and
generations together to accomplish the
exact same goal of breaking the Internet
after all the movies Pixar quality is
not meant to stand in its way of
reaching Disney level successes at the
box office and it seems like there are
no length Disney won't go to to reach
these Heights married a cover up
Disney's acquiring at Pixar has not been
a seamless one especially when it comes
to the criticism surrounding Disney's
appropriation of brave Merida was hailed
as a female protagonist that did not
have time to worry about romantic love
and raced her much more realistic figure
and was not confined by gender
stereotypes when Disney then proceeded
to alter her waist measurements in
preparation for her entrance in the
Disney Princess lineup they received a
lot of criticism for their choices
including merit I and the Disney
Princess scene and Ralph breaks the
Internet definitely demonstrates that
Disney is embracing this heroine as one
of their own but they don't seem ready
to put in center stage just yet she's
not seen in the first shot of the
princesses in their dressing room and
remains very much in the background in
other scenes maybe this is Disney's way
of trying to keep the spotlight off her
which will help keep them free of
unwanted negative feedbacks about how
they represented her character
Twitter users were especially enraged by
Milan's missing appearance in the movie
as well as Ariel's it has been confirmed
however that all three princesses will
stand along their cohorts in the movie
feminine under
not only is Disney trying to take
accountability for its sexist
stereotyping in the past it seems to
also be promoting a feminist message
while Arielle literally gave up her
voice for her chance at love and human
legs
Aurora couldn't provide consent to true
love while in a deep sleep these
messages continue to be reasons for
audiences to question the message and
proceed and Disney princesses have sets
for their impressionable audiences the
much-anticipated and highly popular
scene of Disney Princesses together on
screen for the first time is also
monumental for the decision to
demonstrate self-awareness at how
troubling some of these storylines are
especially in a contemporary context
Penelope is the young heroine who points
this out while bonding over the
assumption that men are required to save
the day this potential for female
bonding sets of a feminist undertone for
the movie that parallels the strength of
Marvel Avengers superheroes to the
wisdom strength and resilience of Disney
Princesses who knows what stories could
be possible when the two are finally put
on equal footing it also suggests that a
Ralph's breaks the internet will be a
departure from an outdated misogynistic
character model and that's all for
hidden messages from Disney Princesses
in wreck-it Ralph - if this is your
first time visiting the things don't
freak to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up
[Music]